[Music]
[Applause]
denis villeneuve has a grasp on
character-driven narrative small and
scope or large in scope
thanks to frank herbert here's a story
that's on that scale but with characters
and relationships and stories
you know these were the things that made
me want to act there is no call we do
not answer there is no faith that we
betray
[Applause]
june is the story of the atreides family
that falls into the trap set by the
emperor who is getting more and more
jealous of their growing popularity
house of tradies stands as a beacon
where every other house in that galaxy
is in reference to that either as
enemies or as friends
he wants to not only make sure that his
people survive but that his son is the
kind of leader that he thinks he should
be paula tradies is the son of duke leto
and lady jessica and my initial
conversation with denis was simply
begging him to you know be able to take
part in the film
the great houses look to us for
leadership and this threatens the
emperor gurney halleck and duncan idaho
did feel like big brothers you know they
rip him especially jason he's the
protector of the traders i mean he's
definitely the head knight who watches
over the family
car
that's a sworn duty i mean if it's with
any honorable
knight soldier does now that dad i mean
that's his family that's what we believe
it's for
bernalick is a combat trainer and he's a
warrior oh man i fight
he's a very strict but fun visceral
paternal maternal he's all of those
things to paul
you are your father you are my son
lady jessica is part of the order of the
benedezurite
this order that she's a part of
we can say make or perhaps the
non-traditional
partner to do gletto this group of women
who carries enormous strength and power
they are bodyguards they are fighters
they can read people
and this is what jessica is having to
deal with being a mother a lover and
there's been a jesuit
how can the emperor
take
everything we've built and give it to
that duke
whereas a gift not a gift
every movie needs it's a bad guys and
the dark onions are the old ancestral
enemies of the attributes the argument
have been a very dark sadistic family in
this galaxy frank herbert created a very
powerful character into baron vladimir
arkhanel he just shows up and then his
shadow looms throughout the film he's a
cause of many people's death he feeds
off fear he feeds off of pain he's a
vicious sadistic person
no squeeze rabbit
squeeze hard yes uncle
and the ferment
kill them all
the feminine are native tribes
people living in a deep desert they have
the capacity to adapt to the toughest
environment deep heat massive sandstorm
dangerous predators all around
stilgar is is the leader of the freyman
he is a powerful character in his
warrior but also as a warrior
he worries about the future
take good care of your family
dr kinds on the surface was seemingly
just somebody who's an ecologist someone
who cares about the foreign but then you
start to understand how much pressure
she is actually under
paul is dreaming about this strange
young woman
that keeps talking to him in his dream
she feels like an old friend again and
someone that like
wants to guide
him follow the friend johnny is native
to
arrakis she's used to this hostility
between her people and the people that
are trying to take from her land
she's a fighter at the end of the day
house of tradies and the harkin of an
ancient grudge and the forces that
they're up against are much greater than
he had anticipated
we're on a path of conflict and it's the
moral catalyst to paul's arc towards
something greater
[Music]
[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
a boy
duncan can i trust you something yes
always you know that
i've been having dreams
about a girl or maracas
i don't know what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
yeah you put on some muscle i didn't
no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling
the emperor asks us to bring peace to
arrakis house atreides accepts
[Music]
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
you've never met hercules before they're
not human they're brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why
kill them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're taking my family off one by one
let's fight back demons
dad
what if i'm not the future of house of
treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead
he's called to it
if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]